well first in this little series we're
doing right now
I love previews game course today
remember seeing it actually at UM PAX
East and I will get this thing a shot
shout out to a new cleaner crew look
like a bit arresting title you know the
dark room with a computer I think that's
the vibe we're going from here home is
made by um abnormals and published by PQ
games
well fine folks over there gave me a
little copy to check out we don't see
what this thing is about so I'm gonna
try to figure this thing out right now
we got to connect I'm just only going to
do that it seems automatically leave
anytime you want but your time away from
the game will have consequences every
second you are absent is a second the
character is left alone and phones
Dauntless and isolation this aim
addresses themes such as anxiety death
loneliness and depression a mental
health information support please visit
stay game.com it's pretty cool got a
little disclaimer going you know say
[Music]
[Music]
interesting
[Music]
I'm a queen
[Music]
I'm the co-star afterworld
what do we have here Albus
waking up in a room with computer all
right all right I guess I'm gonna say
hello
that means hey I don't know what the
wise he's doing all right well it's not
really doing anything interesting
pressing every button and nothing's
happening
all right okay I'm gonna guess a person
throws a little wheel yeah I don't know
Oh beat it in okay all right here we go
[Music]
[Music]
kid that bro that's what's going on I
get to pick where are you where are you
who are you let's go with the who are
you and I don't know if I'm pressing hey
but there's it the way we tell me where
I am I guess I gotta hurt guys trust
you're not the kidnapper so like the
kidnappers will be sadistic and talking
you're the computer watching something
[Music]
we pop it off at the PO you kidnap I
might be the only man that can help you
right now just wanna help
[Music]
I'm heading with the you don't kid and
press of the button over certain places
okay there's a little delay you know
yeah I'm wearing shoes hey hey maybe you
only help all of this problem is real
swallowed a mouthful of goddess kidnap
[Music]
extra the hill I don't know you feel
[Music]
[Music]
also looks like there's a Korean patches
happen based on that choice
yeah you better apologize want me to get
you out of this [ __ ] in there we'll hit
you let's help me that's issue you know
up snarky with me all right so it looks
like that a little control Asia I was
having with a little bit of a delay you
have to wait between you can put inputs
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
very and I'm into lethargic be shocked
he's numb I've just into the dark
[ __ ] hold on a minute
getting out was he doing oh you're gonna
wait a little longer
or you can look at the conversation okay
well that the walls has paint laying off
of everywhere
couldn't find a switch don't stumble on
anything soon they must be and I like
how he corrects his typos but he's
trying to be proper [ __ ] he's kicked out
woman a pattern okay alright alright
alright let's go there's some light on
the situation
[Music]
i'ma go for this early little digging is
foolish but I'm digging it right there
it's actually really perfect for the
[Music]
wall next to me post it would want to
mark crumble and dusty print hanging on
the wall paper marketers tears forming a
circle that beautiful fact of nature a
little bit a little Wi-Fi password it
Aladdin the controls the emotion little
Warblers boy says something like a
watermark of a strange circle scream for
help what I'm screaming for help
let's know what does it say please take
care of this way boys feel free to use
the computer
[Music]
that's what you to figure out what that
Wi-Fi password me you know what honey we
know that mr. keating reference so I'm
gonna have to ask you what that means
yeah I'm serious Pam now I ain't never
seen a dead person sorry I'm sorry will
I spend my time not being kidnapped how
about that Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah bro what happened but it looks like
his emotional states are in this these
bars and something happened ready I
don't know ready beer first out of
nowhere his yellow meter just went down
it's red in that gray meter so obviously
the red must be fear don't face it good
luck
[Music]
[Music]
oh my gosh guys super emotional like go
check it out he said I hope to be right
back
Oh in family
we are going to do something I don't
know what it is
yes I'm connecting this little circuit
thing pressing buttons not to have them
get a control scheme with Barry
doesn't really tell you what
let's both carry
[Music]
the games got to work this controls a
bit walk
I supposed to time it when they circle
try the X button by button B but maybe
not working
not
the game still interesting okay I don't
know what happened okay so that's me
pausing okay all right we got that one
of the buttons working these are ending
this is your stats you could leave at
any time
running this he's a base controls delete
well you can clear your data reset for
the beginning okay and then there's what
I don't like the game does is like if
you press a to select something then you
have to actually press B almost like to
hit return it's acting like a computer
just kind of strange but whatever
connecting again hopefully it's right
back at the part I was
oh no no time he's going right from the
beginning oh no back at where I was at
let's try that again
you don't know what I'm doing it okay
when I move the right hand along okay
I'm getting something out that that's
more than that okay left okay all right
they come get me okay so this is a
puzzle with the analog nothing to do
with a book because I gotta rotate it so
Sergei all right
Godley don't wanna build in figuring out
the colors all got the achievement light
huh all right all right all is not lost
on the control scheme yet all right
optimism
78% of the unit users including you
think that there was always a way out of
every situation so you got a little user
stat going on chapter 2
classroom
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
like issue
[Applause]
there is eat and die you forgo fixation
that's good
[Music]
[Applause]
if your load got another
what's next
[Music]
Carlos jackpot kick that door down bro
[Music]
if you make a fool of yourself how about
you go try you do it they need to let me
have
raining
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
why
all right so you stay in there with your
back shoulder
[Music]
[Music]
I push them too hard he killed himself
we're gonna restart this Saturday
all right second run y'all second way
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
then what is crazy so he was saying that
the door was wrong I should have paid
attention to that clothes okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's funny
[Music]
he's saying the back out that choice
again who say the rola crab at work
[Music]
could be dangerous that now we know what
their door
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
the place
[Music]
and I can see you
[Music]
laughs I will check that out
so the left and right bumpers which is
from
[Music]
selected powers reality
[Applause]
[Music]
kind of similar yet
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
like that like they tell you that
but you are not in position for the
[Music]
we might not get out as good
all right when it's kidnapping
and when we have a fear that problems
well I'm not happy with you know with a
connection I'm I bet mr. tippet
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah let's go down a while
why'd you um I believe
with that or some happen to heart
condition
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
showing concern for him
[Music]
he's just still basically a total
stranger sometime a baby soon I'm not
gonna go through this because get too
much pushback solution
[Music]
and said that the rent goes up creating
a like
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
check that wall
[Music]
at all good advice
nor no choice
and power
[Music]
at hat
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hilarious used to you so 68% told him to
check it back at a poster for a petty
paper chest that's funny I got a nice
little sensor you would this good habit
let's give one more chapter let's go
chapter three of our preview
you've met you got a marital look a
decent kidnappers man well kidnappers
give you a bathroom yeah I mean I let
you handle business got a mirror so you
can look at him some freak out
what they're getting pills because
didn't they Steve say he had a problem
with that
no he's these dudes could be on they
kidnapped and one of his patients
that's a mutt man supposed to be first
you off ramp to freedom this is good
tiny bathroom boasting an empty toilet
sink clog to the car John if you
couldn't look clearly an extra minute
realize you can transform it into gone
item it is toilet clock that would cut
nose in Rancic fatality for a wet dog up
chuckling that's a big big skunk baby
born in a duster
[Music]
you gotta look at this
[Music]
choice is a necessity we see a time this
game has
references are correct that the house
cleared ethic was shattered
check-check man
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all righty
got a frog in his tank
[Music]
[Music]
the positive message
the frog is simple something in your
life they didn't do besides the bat the
gas
nothing viable or keeping
Oh achievement icebreaker are we friends
now we got the icebreaker achievement
hallo mighty Quinn I'll get the tape
[Music]
gotta call my phone
be the Lord to get you out of the
situation oh that's right b2 confirming
I remember B to confirm its election
takes a little adjustment
[Music]
all right buddy easy
what you have yup that's what I keep
telling you bro like oh they kidnapped
you one of your patients kidnapped you
and you and you went away for whatever
your little thing that you don't want to
tell me why you went away and goose it
right you don't want to give me support
into the crib knocks you out give me all
these flashbacks from your past man
that's what it is we check anomaly
evidence all chairs announce out go
right there there
you know she's towards the bathroom area
you see statistics
nothing else I told him check the toilet
tank really be saying all right also
know must not the first one decided to
hide their valuation this far forever
mm-hmm The Godfather finish at before I
can't for no Stan whatever uh-huh what a
fraud get things updated news I like how
he incorrectly spelled in the knee after
actually corrected spelling out funny
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's the symbol on a plate man it's
trash not adequately to answer like that
don't click that one this trash
[Music]
we go really deep thinking man
[Music]
you know what I was going in the stream
here but because I can't have them go
out like that
go replay the string we're gonna play
that shot here have them go out even on
a where this cat came from
so you got the red you got broken plates
with different colors to shave that when
you get you can't like speed the text up
I was just kind of like a collage Dube
different when you were playing a
chapter I would think like once you
reply understanding the beginning they
want to keep these suspense file with
the typing but on what you are you when
you're replaying it to get to some point
they should allow you to kind of speed
up the text one of my little nitpicks
with the game besides to control that to
me about ten minutes to figure huh so
now we back at the plates I told him it
was trash you know that wasn't a good
answer I seem to be misdirected this guy
told him that thing was uh totally dual
was good to go check it out died off of
that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
now I have my curiosity you can't kill
Joey
[Music]
so now you have a kick would you play
[Music]
but no pain no gain says I think your
bands one of you guys
[Music]
I'm assuming this is probably some type
of puzzle mechanic again I'm terrible at
puzzles all seem to involve the analogs
right analog
you gotta wake
under select pieces
okay so right analog moves around it
what you select is
hold hold hold the a and then move it
with the last okay I'm getting
we might be here for a while stream
terrible that stuff like okay I think
this one in
[Music]
[Music]
I'm looking for that bottom piece can
you rotate the pieces so I don't press
the button it will roll looks like the
pieces are set that's actually
healthfully she ain't got to go too
crazy with that I'm gonna get that
bottom piece
there is a little change
okay Allah
[Music]
you're what
[Music]
Oh idiot this one is my bottle peeps
[Music]
power
the big pieces first I guess it looks
like the top okay okay we'll stop up the
wing
definitely hmm
work on the edges the edges are our
friend okay this is around here holla
this oughtta be inside
work on the outer circle
all right get my
[Music]
maybe an inner pea
actually I don't know that too
I guess okay mom
a couple of pieces in the way of a
smallest out of the way there from
velocity
it's gotta be here okay in there we get
it
anymore out of service
all right
hopefully else
[Music]
okay
[Music]
now part of my circle there we go yeah
[Music]
we got some dental pieces inside we
still got one more Paul outside the
circle that I got a fine
since I really don't want to mess with
it oh I hold on all right I didn't want
to mess with that you should yeah I get
that last part
[Music]
maybe
I'm assuming when the part is read
correct
[Music]
all right
[Music]
Oh child
this is the piece I want that's the
reason wait a minute it should be ready
all right progress almost there baby
okay okay wait on you right now don't
know where you're at right now all right
let's get that like this gotta be ready
okay looking shapes nice to get more
intricate design
okay I mean see that for whatever
right here
right
most day baby
all right to boil or [ __ ] lido puzzle
master
there we go
ow
if
boy I'll have you take me wait Katie
Katie I'll be dead every broken plate
there's a naughty cat nice that's the
cat that killed you you'll know polish
training so much folks pure evil boy the
satanic goal was going on where did they
can't come from that's the other
[Music]
Wow that's the thing that killed the
band is eccentric cat ordered a 30% less
likely to have a heart attack I should
really my kid my kid yeah where did the
cat come from let's get to the business
[Music]
[Music]
in the way you noticed that cat
[Music]
the demon cat
[Music]
if is the real right here
[Music]
can't get a dollar to back up big
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you can pick it up
[Music]
[Music]
Oh scratch me
no sound coming from clock when your
life buddy
we will find a way makes it tough oh I
gotta cheer about
ya hear what a psycho cat with a ball on
his back
we got a chill
[Music]
except in the past efficacy yeah let's
get today did you over beat you over the
head and do you in which one of your
patients did it be right back all right
yeah I've probably got industry right
here it's at the for do the easy one do
it all right so who pick the hot one
no pain no gain I guess seems like my
choices seem to be the most favorite
choices but then again you know this is
in conjunction with how many have people
actually playing this game right now you
know this is early review but um yeah
man it's just a this is stake for what
chapters in this is not it's gonna be a
game it's my initial impression this is
gonna be a game that's not for everybody
like this is definitely not there's a
lot of text not a lot of action
you know um the game is trying to
simulate this old-school keyboard for
you like an Apple computer kind of a
deal and Charles a little wonky eye
which is a little doing a little bit of
it better explaining of that I guess
they try to get you all like in the
environment the motif of trying to
figure things out just like how he's
trying to figure things out the
character you're trying to save but um
yeah man I do like it though it's
twisted it's it's silly great writing
early so far I'm very curious to see
where this goes
but um right now I guess I'll or review
you know strong be strong be be to be -
depending on your game track level but
it this is definitely a lower cognitive
type game you know psychological
thriller I gotta figure out what the
whole emotion things is you know I'm
trying to figure that thing out you know
put on yeah I'm digging it mistake from
abnormals the crew at abnormals man
thank you very much and um pqube games
check this thing out PC someone steam
already I believe the Xbox one version
and comes out on what is it the 30th May
30th so check that out and I gotta speak
to the Desmond this would be great or to
switch to I would actually like this let
it go this is this is pretty cool but
there you have it y'all I laud your boy
Lord Cognito
it's the thumbs up for me right now from
stay that's what we